Magnus Carlson rallied and defeated his
self-proclaimed successor alireza faruja
round seven of Norway chess paired
Magnus and alireza a world championship
match that could have been Magnus made
an interesting choice on move 3 eager to
take the game into lesser-known
territory after finishing his own game
Hikaru Nakamura tuned in I just I love
magnus's position here I really really
like it and sure enough Magnus started
to put on the pressure with the
brilliant Queen E1 the game was looking
like a clear victory for Magnus but then
he played the shocking Rook takes E4
playing great move after great move it
was now Ali Reza fighting for a win
pointed out by Fabiano caruana in the
twitch chat alireza had a potential
mating sequence drained from the action
both players repeated moves and agreed
to a draw it was an Armageddon where
Magnus returned to form in dominated not
allowing alireza any chances with little
way to defend alireza resigned one
dramatic twist after the other as